considérant qu'il faut passer d'une
immigration subie à une immigration
choisie
le zéro immigration c'est pas possible
ou alors vous n'a cueilli plus de
familles étrangères pour essayer un
court séjour vun accueillez plus
d'étudiants étrangers dans les
universités et vous permettez plus à vos
jeunes d'aller à l'étranger non plus
puisque souvent les choses peuvent
peut-être dans la réciprocité donc ce
qu'il faut c'est reprendre le contrôle
de nos frontières faire voter
chaque année des plafonds de titres de
séjour par payer par métier il faut
enrayer une émigration de ceux qui
profitent des aides sociales supprimer
le versement des cotisations des
prestations sociales non contributifs
cyr celles qui sont versées sans
contrepartie de cotisation
et il faut remplacer là et me qui est un
gouffre financier par une aide médicale
véritablement réservé à l'urgence
et puis je j'entends le ministre
l'intérieur dire expulsion de tous ceux
qui commettraient des délits graves que
ne l'at il fait avant car nous l'avons
demandé donc vous avez ex gouvernement
nous avons appris à nous méfier et entre
les mots et l'action il ya souvent une
différence considérable donc c'est un
sujet et puis il faut relancer bien sûr
l'intégration et l'assimilation
ça a été possible dans le passé pourquoi
ne le serait ce plus aujourd'hui voilà
évidemment tout ce qui est tout ce qui
donne lieu à détestation de la france
doit être combattu avec la dernière
énergie parce que sinon nous nous en
sortirons pas